I'm here with Alexandra Daddario start
off they watch on the last ever
interview we all be watched John cats
right I mean my god what a journey I now
for being off pretty much the same
question over and over again yes and I
well you know and it's been we've been
traveling for a solid three weeks and
it's you know it when you go all over
the world and go through this whole
process of the movie coming out and it
feels a lot longer than it's been so I
feel like I've been away from home for a
very long time
massive deja vu as well and now that all
the interviews are over and after months
of chat I've got to ask what the
questions you could just quite happily
never hear again these are so often I
mean I think I'm happy to be asked the
you know the typical questions that's
part of promoting as well very good well
it's true I mean I it's not that big of
a deal when you think about the fact
that I get to do what I love that I have
to answer questions about Zak's abs or
about what it's like to diet I mean
those are the questions you hear a lot
but you know as far as a job goes but
that's not that bad it's kind of a good
fit and what does by watching starring
in adaptations as we have always lived
in the castle the super cult novel and
you're in the Percy Jackson films what
is it like starring and something that
has had such a really much-loved
previous life it's it's I think we have
always lived in the castle is very
different than something like Baywatch
or even Percy Jackson because I think
Percy Jackson is huge all over the world
but it's targeted towards a very
specific audience of young people and I
actually wasn't aware of it when I
booked the film because I was a little
too old to have read the books but
there's a great responsibility I think
when you're making any big adaption or
adaptation to especially to a book to do
it justice and people love the story so
much that it's very important to try to
make people you want to tell a story
that people understand and that does the
book justice with Baywatch I think we
were able to sort of take our own have
our own take on it because it's a TV
series that I
think people loved but don't take us
seriously in the sense that there's a
lot of things about it that seem
ridiculous now that you're able to poke
fun at lovingly and you know make into
something wrong here and and a little
bit different I loved it I literally
laughed all the way through it really
Gattaca lee was my husband was going oh
god it was equipment some quite gone
magically yeahi'm I grew up with it
loads of my friends that I grew up
watching it at my family and I loved the
insane storylines did you ever watch it
at all and so you have a favorite you
know I never watched it but I knew
exactly what it was just because it's
Baywatch and you know Pamela Anderson
and you know David Hasselhoff being
tuned and all the music but you know it
and you hear about their lives and who
they're dating and what parties are
going to and you grow up sort of knowing
who these people are and knowing that
Baywatch is you know something that it's
like a crime show on the beach and it's
a sexy crime show and so I watched some
episodes in preparation for the movie
and and you know some of the episodes
are completely off the wall yes I would
try watching them it was the best one
yeah it's not that but I'll have to do
that but I think that that's what makes
this movie also you can make the movie
off the water because they took these
scenarios very seriously when making the
the show and then we were able to
program a fact well Zack certainly took
that they watch physique to new new
extremes who you think had a tougher job
of getting ready for the shoot the boys
or the girls I think you know that his
his whole thing was very interesting
because he actually made this character
choice to build this this athlete who
was very self-involved and quite frankly
a douchebag and his character choice was
to get this body that you know is insane
and that was sort of his choice as far
as his own his own vanity his own
arrogance his own insecurities trying to
cover it up by the way he looked so he
went crazy with the panning and the hair
was ridiculous and and the abs were you
know not normal person abs because I
think that that was a character choice
and I was really quite impressed by his
dedication to his role and really build
this character so I think that he took
it to another level I think that the
girls we worked really hard and there
was some pressure but I think that I
think that we had actually maybe not
easier it was just different yeah you
know it's just a different level of
amazing but it was so funny
another thing that I really loved about
it because I was just like yes we all
look absolutely banging but also just
the jokes endless it's absolutely fun
right and I think that was one of the
great things about this movie was being
on set and being able to have ridiculous
things come out of your mouth you then
let them end up in the film and we were
talking in our hey it's okay podcast the
other day about that thing that can we
say difficult sign which is like body
confidence on the beach and that sort of
thing what's your philosophy about this
mythical beach body I think you know I
think it's hard for I you know as a
young woman I never anticipated my
career would go this way we're on like a
Baywatch babe or somebody's considered
you know very sexy and the kinds of
roles that I do and I think that I'm in
my 30s now and I think that as I've
gotten older I found more confidence and
who I am and how I look and I think that
that's something that you just learned
through life and if I can say to any
young women or young men I think that
being yourself is the best thing that
you can be and I think that we always
try to sort of fit in or be something
else and my best advice is to try to
find confidence and love who you are and
you know it doesn't always work but I
think that that's the main thing I found
now in my early thirties sort of okay
I'm not the same as everybody else my
personality or my sense of humor but I'm
I'm okay the way that I am and I'm happy
with who I am how do you cope with the
kind of scrutiny that comes from just
being an actress
full-stop mean even a game for over a
decade and I was doing my usual goddamn
interviewing somebody today panic
googling this morning and the means the
first stories that came up were just
like Alexandra Daddario does nip slip at
Berlin premiere and that's a tiny lilius
crap you know I think
I've never actually faced I've never
considered myself famous I've considered
myself a working actress so I think on
this press tour I've dealt with more
scrutiny than I have before and it's
challenging it's definitely difficult
interesting interesting you should
mention that thing because I found I did
see that and found it to be I was at
first horrified but then you know you
talk to people and it's like every time
somebody wears something that that's the
headline and you know I think that I'm
going through this process of learning
and learning from my mistakes and and
you haven't made a mistake but I would I
wouldn't say it's a mistake I just say
sort of figuring out who I am and and
it's a very interesting thing to have
people look at everything you do and and
try to find a headline for it I mean so
and I'm trying to figure out how to just
deal with that I guess is the best way
to put it yeah I mean people do you want
to just put headline to an outfit and do
you ever feel that the media feels done
obviously I can't myself enough as I'm a
journalist do you feel that the media
can get away with more just before your
you have the audacity to wear a swimsuit
on screen oh I don't know I mean I think
that I think that people are it's a
combination of people looking for
headlines and and this sort of there's
quite a bit of hypocrisy as far as the
way that women are being talked about
and the way that even that people see
how women should be portraying
themselves and people feel you know
people have different opinions about all
kinds of things and there's a million
different people in the world and my
view of it is that with as far as women
and equality goes I think that the whole
thing is that we have the right to to
choose the roles we want and to wear
what we want and and you know there's
stuff that comes along with doing
Baywatch that is awkward but also
Baywatch I don't take myself too
seriously and I think everybody has a
good sense of humor and the whole point
of Baywatch is that we're sort of
in bathing suits in great shape running
on the beach and they would lay down
suspects right and I hope people go and
see the movie and and laugh and that was
sort of the whole point yeah especially
I mean it's knit I saw your brilliant
post at the time of the women's March
which I went to our version here in
London and what was it like
did you what was it like being on the
set of a comedy whilst all this sort of
political turmoil was going on was it
nice was a good distraction or did you
talk about politics on set
um yeah I do and I do talk about
politics and you know I think you do get
very involved in the world your and I
don't know that I was on set although it
was maybe right right afterwards or
something but it's been a very
interesting year and I have very strong
opinions but I don't you know really
discuss something publicly but I think
that it's been an interesting year and
I'm glad that we're having the
conversation and I think you know
ultimately that women need to be spoken
about and it's it's not acceptable like
I said in my tweet for people to speak
about women the way that they're spoken
about and there's this whole idea of
that's just the way it is and the
locker-room talk saying and I don't
think that we need to accept that as
that's the way that it is and so that's
sort of I'm glad that we're having the
conversation well enlighten news did you
pick up any tips on healthy has
basically be a badass on instagram from
working with the rock again because that
man is a social media powerhouse he is
and social media has become so important
for actors and for you know people in
the public eye and for promoting films
and he's really taught me I think you
now doing my second film with him you
know how you can use it as a positive
tool and you know when I'm promoting a
film I promote a film and then I love to
use it to tweet to tweet and Instagram
photos of my dog who I think is the
cutest dog in the world so I think it
can be a really fun thing and then also
a very good tool and I do sort of look
and see what what things
work and what what don't but I think
there's a very smart way to use that yes
definitely um and obviously we're going
to act again with rock it's a time for
some addresses it would be making
amazing and does your relationship on
set sort of change depending on the type
of movie do you have more laughs when
it's more serious to take more seriously
when it's a comedy yeah I mean yes yeah
but every movie that you do is for San
Andreas it's it's you know more dramatic
and I think you have to keep I'm a big
believer in no matter what film you're
making that you should keep this set
light and you have to take things
seriously when it's time to take things
seriously but also you want everyone to
be having a good time and feel like
they're part of something where you can
sort of be yourself and joke around and
then we know when it's time to be
serious so I think for Baywatch we were
able to make more penis jokes and be
more ridiculous and we had the freedom
to really bring around senses of humor
to to the rules I love it so you've
basically been an athlete mode for the
last two years probably more how are you
going to unwind now that the tour is
over
I did have I did have I did a couple of
films in between Baywatch and promoting
Baywatch one was in Dublin and one was
in New Orleans and I definitely and I
did some unwinding there some drinking
and some eating because there's great
food in the south and in and in Ireland
so I think you know when I'm I know when
it's time to move throughout a film and
shoot a film and what shape I need to be
in and then I I'm lucky enough that I
can get away with what just meant if
you're going to catch up on Netflix oh
yeah oh yeah oh I thought you're in
Hungary winners guys's um yeah no I know
I'm going to catch up on Netflix there's
a lot of shows to see and hang out with
my dog and hike yeah and pictures do and
please for just relax
one last thing so we're about to wrap up
but we were talking before the interview
started about the problems being very
pale and having fake tans yes you
mentioned that you had your fake tan CGI
on at one point the biggest struggle in
this film was the tan so you have
someone come to your apartment twice a
week to to spray tan you and then you
get into the trailer in the morning and
you'd still be blotchy so they have to
put me
up all over you and at one point just on
my chest it was just no way to cover it
so they did have to fix it in post which
is where they go through every frame and
they clean it up because it did look
like I had you know a condition or
something
so the panning was really it was a
constant thing way more than the diet or
the hair or anything else it was de
tanning if anybody can come in CGI me
before the glamour Awards on Tuesday
they'll be totally amazing Alexandra
thank you so much thank you so much like
Facebook thank you